Voici mon "draw my life".
Ou mon "dessine ma vie" en français.
Mais ça fait un p'tit peu nul "dessine ma vie", quand même.
Je vais d'abord vous parler de mes parents
qui sont nés juste là
en Roumanie.
Alors ne faites pas attention à
l'Angleterre qui ressemble à une...heu...
Alors, la Roumanie c'étaient pas la grosse, grosse ambiance à l'époque
puisque c'était la dictature communiste.
Mes parents m'ont raconté que là-bas
on était obligés d'aller voter
mais pour un seul candidat ...
le dictateur !
Du coup ça laissait peu de place à
l'hésitation en fait.
Et ma grand-mère trouvait ça débile
donc elle voulait pas aller voter.
Mais quand la police est venue
Heu...elle a changé d'avis en fait.
Finalement... finalement elle voulait bien.
Mes grands-parents ont donc fuit la dictature
pour arriver en France
où l'ambiance était quand même meilleure.
Et c'est là que mes parents se sont rencontrés.
Vous... Vous trouvez pas que la roumanie ressemble un peu à... à Nemo ?
Hein?
Laissez tomber...
Je suis né le 12 mai 1989
à Nice sous les palmiers
et les vieux qui crament au soleil.
Et j'ai un grand frère,
une petite soeur,
et un petit frère qui adore brûler des voitures !
Non je déconne, je déconne ...
Il adore jouer à Minecraft.
Ça c'est vrai par contre.
J'ai toujours été proche de mon grand frère.
Enfin surtout son poing de mon visage.
On se chamaillait tous le temps.
Je lui pinçais un peu l'épaule,
Il me cassait les genoux...
C'était équitable.
Avec mon grand-frère on était les opposés en quelque sorte.
Lui c'était un petit peu une terreur.
C'qui fait qu'à ma rentrée au collège, en
sixième,
un surveillant m'a dit
"Oh non... Pas encore un Iov..."
Très envie d'aller au collège après ça. Vraiment !
Alors, je sais que dans tous les "Draw my life", il faut dire qu'on était martyrisé à l'école tout ça.
Moi franchement ça allait,
Bon y'avait juste un élève qui s'acharnait sur moi en sixième.
Mais j'l'ai revu deux ans
après on avait tous grandis et....
Ah non! Ah non ! Sauf lui en fait ...
Et ben franchement, ça l'a rendu beaucoup plus sympa.
J'ai jamais eu une tonne d'amis.
Ils étaient peu mais on était pareil.
On adorait créer des trucs et j'en vois
certains encore aujourd'hui.
On passait nos week-ends et nos vacances
à inventer des histoires pour en faire des BDs,
à faire des sketchs audios,
à faire de la musique,
à créer des jeux sur RPG Maker.
On.. on passait un peu pour des geeks
mais on s'en foutait pas mal.
A 16 ans j'ai fait un job d'été
dans un magasin de matériaux de construction.
En gros je devais porter des trucs lourds pour des clients.
C'était très chiant.
Mais quand j'avais une minute de libre
je prenais un stylo.
et je dessinais en cachette sur les sacs de ciment.
Parfois les clients me demandaient les sacs avec les dessins.
Probablement pour me faire plaisir.
Mais ça marchait, ça me faisait vraiment plaisir.
Toutes ces créations
que je faisais seul ou avec mes potes
je les mettais sur mon blog.
Sauf les sacs de ciment bien sur.
et puis un jour, en 2007,
j'ai décidé de faire une vidéo avec le
caméscope de mes parents
et de la mettre sur internet.
Et là ...
C'est le méga buzz.
Ah non !
Ah non, en fait non pas du tout ...
Mais c'est pas grave.
Je voulais juste créer des trucs.
Et les sites comme Dailymotion ou
YouTube
me permettaient de créer des nouvelles choses.
Alors j'ai continué et j'ai fait des centaines de vidéos.
Même avec 3 de moyenne en allemand,
j'ai eu mon bac.
J'avais décidé de faire une école préparatoire économique et commerciale
et on m'a dit :
"Non!"
Du coup j'ai... j'ai... j'ai fait une fac d'économie à Aix en Provence,
ce qui me laissait quand même
plus de temps qu'une prépa
pour faire mes vidéos sur mon blog.
Et pendant l'année scolaire :
*Bzzzz !*
"Oui, allo?"
"Chhht!"
On me proposait un travail sur Paris :
faire des vidéos pour un site d'actualité.
Alors j'ai beaucoup hésité,
genre euh ... une seconde.
Et j'ai accepté.
Mes parents savaient pas trop
si c'était une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle.
Du coup ils m'ont dit
"Si ça marche pas ton job sur Paris
tu reprends les études?"
"Bien sûr papa, bien sûr maman."
Je n'ai jamais remis les pieds dans une fac.
En arrivant sur Paris j'ai eu de la chance
puisque j'ai trouvé un petit duplex de 180m2
en plein coeur de la capitale.
Non je déconne hein !
J'dormais par terre chez des potes
Mais c'était cool aussi !
Et j'ai surtout rencontré des
gens qui faisaient comme moi
des vidéos sur internet.
Y' avait des grands,
des petits,
des ados,
des chevelus,
et encore des petits.
Et d'un coup on a tous buzzé de ouf !
Ah non !
Ah non ... En fait non toujours pas.
Mais c'est pas grave.
À l'époque personne ne se faisait connaitre sur internet
ou même gagnait sa vie.
On fait des vidéos juste parce que ça nous plaît.
Et progressivement
vous avez été de plus en plus nombreux
à regarder toutes ces vidéos.
Comme quoi il fallait,
fallait juste pas abandonner.
Un jour on m'a proposé de faire mes
vidéos sur une chaîne de télé
tous les jours.
En plus j'avais carte blanche.
Je pouvais pas refuser.
Et j'avais même réussi à faire embaucher mon pote Maxime Musqua pour m'aider.
On s'amusait vraiment bien.
Mais les vidéos sur internet ça me manquait,
et c'était là où j'étais le plus à l'aise.
Alors, j'ai arrêté l'émission
Puis la chaîne se mettait à diffuser les
anges de la télé-réalité
avec délire et façon pour les connaisseurs.
Aujourd'hui le caméscope a un peu changé.
mais je suis toujours sur internet.
Le week-end que je passais avec mes potes
à créer des trucs
c'est devenu mon quotidien.
Et ça c'est grâce à vous.
Alors je vous remercie vraiment.
J'ai plein d'idées
et plein de projets que j'ai hate de vous montrer.
Mais ça c'est dans mes prochaines vidéos